flammenwalze in brandenburg außer
kontrolle mehrere ortschaften müssen
noch in der nacht evakuiert werden bei
der brandbekämpfung mit über 400
einsatzkräften werden sieben
feuerwehrmänner verletzt unaufhörlich
scheint sich die feuerwalze im süden von
brandenburg auf mehr als 800 hektar
auszubreiten eine fläche die mehr als
1100 20 fußballfeldern entspricht der
sieg gegen die flammen ist noch lange
nicht erreicht in der nacht kämpften
mehrere hundert feuerwehrleute aus
brandenburg und dem angrenzenden sachsen
gegen das entfernen ja und mehrere
ortschaften im umkreis wurden evakuiert
über 300 menschen müssen ihre häuser
verlassen
stelle einer schweinemastanlage wurden
von der flammenfront gefressen brannten
samt ihren völlig aus und die hoffnung
für die nächsten tage drei
löschhubschrauber der bundespolizei wie
auch der bundeswehr sowie der einsatz
zweier wasserwerfer der landespolizei
sie werden hier erwartet und unser bild
reporter julian stehle ist für uns in
brandenburg unterwegs in der nähe dieser
brände julian wie ist die aktuelle
situation
ja ich stehe hier in einem ort bei
falkenberg ist corsa wurde auch gestern
evakuiert das heißt eigentlich ist hier
totenstille hinter mir auf einem feld
den kann man leider jetzt nicht sehen
weil da das feuerwehrauto davor steht
aber da steht der erste
löschhubschrauber der hier am heutigen
morgen tatsächlich sehnsüchtig erwartet
wird insgesamt drei hubschrauber sollen
hier fliegen und das große problem ist
beim waldbrand einfach dass wenn es
munitions verdachtsfläche ist dann kommt
man in den wald nicht hinein und dann
hat man buchstäblich nur zwei
möglichkeiten entweder entweder es
regnet sehr stark oder man muss mit dem
löschhubschrauber von oben löschen und
der regen ist tatsächlich auch ein gutes
stichwort ich habe mich gerade eben noch
ganz aktuell mit dem wald
brandschutzbeauftragten des landes
brandenburg unterhalten und der sagt
einfach uns fehlt ein ganzes jahr regen
das muss man sich mal vorstellen also es
hat so wenig geregnet die böden sind so
ausgetrocknet und aus gedauert dass wir
ein ganzes jahr regen wieder aufholen
müssten und das ist halt die große
brandgefahr in brandenburg deshalb
brennen die brände immer wieder nicht
nur hier bei falkenberg zum beispiel
auch parallel gerade im landkreis
oranienburg oberhavel auch da gibt es
einen großen waldbrand und die kräfte
gerade frei willige feuerwehrkräfte die
kämpfe hier an allen fronten hinter mir
dann ein paar kilometer weiter in den
wald hinein da wurden gerade kräfte
abgelöst hier sind feuerwehren aus
potsdam aus potsdam mittelmark natürlich
aus dem gesamten landkreis elbe-elster
hier im einsatz und man darf nicht
vergessen das sind zum großen teil
freiwillige einsatzkräfte also die
familien warten zuhause mann kam von der
arbeit gestern und ist dann zum
waldbrand gefahren und seit so vielen
stunden hier im einsatz meiner meinung
nach echt ne tolle leistung also großer
zusammenhalt unter den einsatzkräften du
hast dem löschhubschrauber gerade schon
angesprochen wie versucht man denn jetzt
herr der lage zu werden und das ganze in
den griff zu bekommen
ja das kann ich euch sagen hinter mir
wird gerade einen puffer becken
aufgebaut das thw ist hier im einsatz
die feuerwehr ist mit
tanklöschfahrzeugen hier die haben
wasser geladen ein tlf 4000 dann zb 4000
liter wasser und dieses wasser wird dann
in dieses puffer becken abgegeben dann
kann der hubschrauber starten und er hat
unten quasi einen wasserkopf dran füllt
diesen wasser korb mit wasser und fliegt
dann auf kürzestem wege ins
waldbrandgebiet und wirft dann dort die
tausende liter wasser ab das reicht aber
nicht einmal das reicht nicht zweimal da
wird der hubschrauber mehrere tage
fliegen bis dann wirklich ein großer
löscherfolg zu sehen ist die gute
nachricht in diesem in dieser ganzen
katastrophe ist dass zumindestens die
ausbreitung eingedämmt wurde jetzt ist
die große hoffnung dass der wind nicht
auffrischt weil der führt dann dazu dass
die flammen wieder angefacht werden
können und auch dann kann sich der
waldbrand wieder ausbreiten und auch
noch eine weitere gute nachricht heute
morgen die ortschaften konnten gehalten
werden also für alle evakuierten
bürgerinnen und bürger ist erstmal die
nachricht die feuerwehr hat die flammen
vor den ortschaften gestoppt und löscht
aber jetzt weiter und es bleibt weiter
angespannt aber das hat sich doch
erstmal ganz gut an julian stelle besten
dank für diese informationen live aus
brandenburg
[Musik]